[Musica]
io vengo dal veneto e dalle mie parti si
dice prediche corte soppresse long che
significa discorsi corti e soppresse
quindi cose da mangiare abbondanti
questo per dire che il ted in realtà
probabilmente l'abbiamo inventato noi
ben prima del 1984
io di solito sono dietro quel palco lo
sono come organizzatore lo sono anche
per lavoro perché nell'ultimo terzo
della mia vita il mio lavoro è stato
aiutare le persone a parlare in pubblico
a raccontarsi a comunicare quelle che in
qualche modo le loro emozioni e ho
aiutato una scienziata che ha scoperto
il moto di rotazione dei satelliti di
urano che poi ha dovuto spiegare come
quella scoperta in qualche modo l'abbia
aiutata ad affrontare la malattia rara
del proprio figlio
ho aiutato una preside straordinaria
dell'istituto di caivano che in
periferia di napoli una donna che
combatte contro la camorra e la
dispersione scolastica e quindi avendo
aiutato tutte queste persone eccezionali
mi chiedo cosa faccio su questo bollino
rosso ma in realtà secondo me è la
domanda è un po più fine e io vorrei
girarla a voi se voi poteste salire su
questo bollino rosso se poteste per
dieci quindici venti minuti della vostra
vita avere una platea e raccontare le
idee che cambiano il mondo cosa direste
pensateci il mio lavoro non è lavorare
su quello che le persone dicono ma sul
come lo dicono ci aiutare ad organizzare
il loro discorso allora potrei dare un
suggerimento su come si organizza un
testo perfetto e ci sono le solite cose
scrive dall'inizio alla fine
stare attenti sul imparare a memoria
perché se uno scrive un discorso che
vuole imparare a memoria un casino
perché se poi non si ricorda un
passaggio sballo ora perché non si
ricorda più il filo logico raccontare
gli aneddoti dell'infanzia sissi su
tutte e tecniche sono tutte cose
interessanti ma ci sono delle cose più
importanti è la prima la prima cosa
importante per chi nella propria vita
vuole parlare che sia sul palco di un
tetto che sia in un colloquio di lavoro
che sia con i propri figli che sia in
una relazione
la prima cosa la più importante è
credere nel potere delle parole
il più grande pensatore del novecento
che albus silente dice uno dei più
grandi eroi del novecento che harry
potter che le parole sono la nostra più
importante fonte di magia ed è vero
perché le parole trasformano la realtà
infatti ho voluto portarvi 33 esempi di
parole che hanno cambiato il corso della
storia la prima è un discorso che
sicuramente conoscete tutti è un
discorso che si impara a catechismo è il
discorso delle beatitudini
il discorso di un uomo che sale sul
monte si siede dice matteo evangelista
che per la prima volta quell'uomo
parlano nei suoi discepoli ma alle folle
quindi parla universalmente e quell'uomo
con quel discorso capovolge la piramide
dei valori del tempo al tempo chi è che
comandava chi era in cima alla piramide
dei valori
l'imperatore sarà la divinizzazione
dell'imperatore l'imperatore era dio
l'imperatore era il potere e quindi la
gerarchia dei valori cosa prevedeva in
cima alla gerarchia dei valori il potere
l'onore la forza la essere vincenti e
quell'uomo benchè annuncia una profezia
non c'è una parola che non sia ancora
rivelata del tutto ma che ha cambiato il
corso della storia dicendo che invece
dio dove si manifesta si manifestano i
poveri negli ultimi negli immigrati
nelle persone con disabilità nelle
persone che sono in ferme per cui una
parola rivelatrice che ancora non si è
compiuta che significa pauperismo no
quel discorso non ha significato il
pauperismo il pauperismo significa
scegliere di vivere la povertà il
discorso delle beatitudini nell'amare il
nostro nemico ci dice una cosa diversa
ci significa accettare la sofferenza
all'interno della nostra vita la povertà
è una sfiga non è una cosa bella ma la
povertà fa parte della vita e le
beatitudini che sono un discorso che ha
cambiato il corso della storia ci
insegnano ad accettare anche quella
sofferenza e una parola talmente forte
talmente rivelatrice che gli apostoli
cosa dicono che è come un tesoro che
viene portato in vasi di creta
cioè noi siamo vasi di creta è una
parola talmente forte una appare la
parola talmente grande che contiene un
anelito d'amore che ciascuno deve
portare una parola di conforto e di
speranza nei confronti del prossimo la
seconda parola non è proprio un discorso
ma è una parola che secondo me deve
entrare nel nostro dibattito pubblico
una parola che voglio citare perché è
recente e a che fare con un fatto la
settimana scorsa
l'ambiente è entrato nella costituzione
italiana
per la prima volta l'ambiente entra
nella costituzione italiana perché dico
questa cosa perché nella nostra
costituzione che è una delle
costituzioni più belle del mondo questo
tema non c'era cosa significa che i
padri costituenti erano poco attenti no
voglio raccontarvi un aneddoto che
testimonia quanto invece il dibattito
per esempio sul primo articolo della
nostra costituzione sia stato un
dibattito ricchissimo sapete che c'è
stato il referendum monarchia repubblica
vince la repubblica si elegge
un'assemblea costituente e questi
costituenti che erano degli uomini degli
uomini come noi si trovano a dover
scrivere la carta che tenesse insieme il
nostro vivere democratico ed erano
persone che venivano da estrazioni da
storie da posti del paese totalmente
diverse
si erano unite per combattere il
fascismo per combattere la dittatura ma
trovare un linguaggio comune per capire
su cosa dovesse fondarsi la nostra
democrazia è una qualcosa di molto
difficile tanto che nella
sottocommissione presieduta da meuccio
ruini sapete che c'erano tre
sottocommissioni è quella che si doveva
occupare dei diritti dei principi
fondamentali alla la prima non si riesce
a trovare un compromesso su il punto che
dovesse dare vita alla democrazia
italiana alla repubblica italiana
allora due grandissime figure un
professorino democristiano che si
chiamava dossetti e un altro grande
un'altra grandissima figura che si
chiamava togliatti si incontrarono di
nascosto perché nelle commissioni nel
dibattito parlamentare qualcosa non
stava funzionando si incontrarono di
nascosto in una laterale di via del
corso sono testimonianze bellissime di
questo e passano i convenevoli su cosa
deve fondarsi la repubblica italiana
allora dossetti dice ma guardi parli
letto gli atti le è un uomo che ha
grande esperienza internazionale
non ho dossetti parli lei lei ha
studiato io guardi sono una persona che
non ha studiato parli lei allora
dossetti dice per me la repubblica
italiana deve fondarsi sul lavoro e
togliatti dice ma lei lo dice
perché vuole compiacermi e dossetti dice
no io non lo faccio per compiacere lei
so che nella visione comunista il
proletariato quindi coloro che lavorano
devono diventare la classe dirigente ma
io dico che la repubblica italiana deve
fondarsi sul lavoro perché penso che un
individuo diventi persona quando
acquista la dignità e cosa fa acquistare
la dignità la possibilità di sporcarsi
le mani di lavorare e questo è il motivo
che ha portato all'inserimento del
lavoro all'interno del primo articolo
della costituzione questo per dire cosa
che fu un dibattito straordinario che le
parole vanno accarezzate le parole vanno
cercate l'articolo 2 addirittura stato
frutto di un dibattito asprissimo perché
qualcuno diceva che la repubblica
dovesse essere fonte dei diritti e
invece i parlamentari dissero no non
deve essere fonte dei diritti la
repubblica riconosce e tutela i diritti
ma i diritti non mi vengono dati in
quanto c'è un ente che li riconosce
ma i diritti mi vengono dati perché sono
una persona e questo perché perché
sapevano che le parole avevano cambiato
il corso della storia anche in termini
negativi quindi la democrazia si fonda
anche sulla potenza delle parole il
terzo discorso di cui vorrei parlarvi è
sicuramente un discorso che avete
conosciuto di cui avete sentito parlare
è l'hub ad ring di maio di martin luther
king sulle mani quanti lo conoscono
ok adesso per cortesia siate sinceri
quanti l'hanno veramente sentito cioè la
hanno visto l'hanno vista al di là di
sapere di cosa si parla quanti l'hanno
visto è un po meno
07 us that it has just begun bond entro
fine mese ma eccomi riccione lu wan
della vela nation guatemala bichard
marco rebeschi kong bergamo
ok io voglio far vedere questo discorso
non per questa parte che forse la più
importante che è quella chiaramente del
sogno di nascita una nazione in quei
figli non vengano giudicati dal colore
della pelle ma dal proprio carattere
ma per chiedergli di prestare attenzione
ad un'altra caratteristica sentite come
vengono scandite le parole quando si
prepara un discorso pubblico ci sono tre
elementi che vanno considerati il non
verbale quindi come im presento cosa
sono cosa sono su questo palco il par a
verbale che qui ha molto importanti
silenzi le pause
ci sono delle figure retoriche per
esempio l'anafora che la ripetizione che
aiutano molto a scandire il ritmo di un
discorso e poi c'è tutto il tema
chiaramente del verbale quello che
vorrei consegnarli a che quando si parla
entrambi gli elementi vanno presi in
considerazione che per fare un bel
discorso
tutti questi elementi vanno presi in
considerazione quindi c'è un tema di
fisicità c'è un tema di allenamento il
corpo è uno strumento quando parliamo il
nostro corpo va trattato bene è uno
strumento con cui noi ci mettiamo in
relazione con gli altri
il terzo tema chiaramente il verbale e
sul verbale quindi sulla ricerca
l'importanza delle parole un grande del
passato catone diceva rent m verba
sequentur cosa significa che le parole
vanno conosciute va conosciuto
l'argomento le parole verranno e per
questo dobbiamo ricordarci il primo
pilastro di cui ha voluto parlarvi è
credere che le parole possono cambiare
il mondo
il secondo è allenarsi e come si allena
al paraverbale come scusate come si
allena verbale leggendo tanto leggendo
quello che per un artista scusate quello
che per un atleta è la dieta che è
fondamentale per chiunque faccia sport
per chi vuole parlare per chi vuole
utilizzare bene il potere della parola e
leggere tanto essere curiosi essere
costantemente curiosi
la terza diciamo quindi la prima credere
nel potere della parola
il secondo è curare le parole allenarsi
e la terza e ricordarsi che quando si
parla in qualche modo si diventa dei
leader allora cosa sono i leader
sentiamo sempre parlare di questa parola
i leader sono le persone più forti sono
le persone più capaci sono le persone
più intelligenti non sempre un leader e
una persona capace di guidare un
processo e ciascuno di noi
nella vita diventa leader per un
processo e quando parla il leader perché
porta a quel processo a diventare un
processo di comunicazione
allora un leader deve essere prima di
tutto autorevole nel senso che deve
sapere di cosa sta parlando io potrei
leggere prendere wiki pd a leggere tutta
la descrizione della meccanica
quantistica e fare uno speech sulla
meccanica quantistica
ma non sarai autorevole perché se voi mi
chiedete il perché di un equazione non
saprei rispondere
un leader deve essere giusto cosa
significa quando si fa un discorso
essere giusti motivare e spiegare i
perché delle cose che si dicono cosa
significa essere un leader giusto che
noi non abbiamo in odio i professori che
erano più severi con noi professori
carlo severi ce li ricordiamo anche con
piacere perché ci hanno fatto sudare
quelli che magari ricordiamo come
l'affetto sono quelli che pensavamo
facessero delle ingiustizie quindi un
leader non deve mai dire quando si parla
mai dire perché è così ma motivare il
perché così è il terzo tema essere se
stessi
ciascuno ha una sua personalità abbiamo
sentito oggi su questo palco persone con
delle personalità veramente diverse come
hanno fatto a entrare nei vostri cuori
essendo loro stessi raccontandosi per
quello che sono veramente
l'importante è cercare di non essere
diversi da quello che si è anche quando
si parla ed arrivare così al cuore
allora io per esempio a una avuto una
storia importante e depressione quando
avevo vent'anni e questo mi ha aiutato a
cercare di diventare più empatico
cercare di capire nel corso della mia
vita che avrei voluto parlare di questo
tema di questa piaga di cui non si parla
mai abbastanza cercando di trasformare
la concezione che la debolezza sia una e
la depressione sia una debolezza
ricordando invece che una malattia
lavorare su questo fare
sensibilizzazione su questo quindi anche
le nostre storie in qualche modo possono
raccontare qualcosa di noi e quello con
cui voglio in qualche modo lasciarvi
tutti i te definiscono con una call to
action è usare veramente le parole per
trasformare la realtà
provate a pensare chiudete gli occhi e
pensate a qualcuno a cui non avete detto
una cosa che avete nel cuore al datore
di lavoro a cui non avete avuto il
coraggio di dire che vorreste cambiare
qualcosa ai vostri genitori alla vostra
compagna ai vostri figli ciascuno di noi
sa qualcosa e tramite la parola
ora può trasformare quella realtà allora
io per esempio sono contento di essere
su questo palco perché oggi sono qui con
i miei genitori e so che non lavora
magari altre occasioni per cui è giusto
il kairos e al momento giusto dire che
sono orgoglioso di quello che mi hanno
dato e spero che loro siano orgogliosi
orgogliosi di quello che noi come figli
siamo diventati o un'altra cosa che
vorrei consegnare a questo ted
questa è una conchiglia del cammino di
santiago
chi parte per fare il cammino sa che
deve partire con lo zaino molto leggero
perché lo zero del cammino dica santiago
è lo zaino delle proprie paure e quindi
siccome il tema di questo tether e mare
io voglio lasciare questa con figlia gli
organizzatori ma ne ho
un'ultima che per una persona siccome
credo nel potere del sì una persona che
ieri che anna che ieri ha acconsentito
in qualche modo attraverso il potere di
una parola che si di continuare insieme
un cammino quindi di sposarci e di
remare dalla stessa parte
[Applauso]